new technology in cars is significantly
it's significantly rather cutting the
number of backup crashes a new report
released overnight shows promising test
results from the rear crash test rear
automatic braking an option in just five
percent of new vehicles is linked to a
62 percent drop in reported accidents in
cars with that equipment Kris Van Cleave
is in Falls Church Virginia with a
report Chris good morning good morning
and those fender benders can cause
thousands of dollars in damage or worse
that's why you have backup cameras to
help you spot obstacles and people that
may be moving behind you add in backup
sensors and now automatic braking and
you can cut reported accidents up to 78
percent it was so shocking and sudden
Michael Dolan will never forget the day
his daughter died in 2010 a neighbor
backed out of his driveway not seeing
two-year-old Abigail was behind the car
I went to and had to climb under a car
and and pick up her body it was it was
it was a hard day starting in May all
new cars in the US will be required to
have a rear view camera some automakers
are going further adding backup warning
sensors and now reverse automatic
braking for the first time the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety tested the
combination of technologies the 2017
Subaru Outback and Cadillac XTS you ve
earned superior ratings for other
vehicles scored and advanced rating for
generally avoiding a collision or
substantially reducing the vehicle speed
but there's some room to improve this
car did not stop before a driver backed
into a dummy car parked at an angle
David zoobi is the Institute's chief
research officer that we're autobrake
the sensors the cameras are going to
prevent a lot of property damage grasses
and and we hope they're also going to
prevent some crashes involving
people Dahlan hopes the technology will
one day mean no other parent has to lose
a child like he did I still have you
know stop nightmares let's talk
flashbacks and I wish that I don't want
anybody to go through it right now the
backup braking systems are designed to
preventing accidents involving obstacles
that do damage like this but car makers
are working on adapting it so it can
also protect pedestrians passing by the
cameras now front auto braking that's
supposed to become standard in most cars
by 2022 but when it comes to the backup
breaking there is no plan to make it
standard John Chris thanks any of us
with kids I want to know which
automakers are gonna put that as an
option in their cars because I think a
lot of parents would say that's a car
with five yeah absolutely and we'd want
to pay extra for it too yeah then you
get your neighbors to buy it